so the creator economy recession is here
this isn't hype we're going to be
looking at real data in this video in
fact mr beast's manager
shared an insider document with the
creators that they manage uh talking
about with the market in free fall
content creators need to prepare
for the worst another article said that
major streamers are reevaluating how
they do business amid recession fears
and business insider revealed that
layoffs are hitting the creator economy
and brand deals are being
canceled and so in this video
we're going to be talking about the six
things you need to know in order to
prepare yourself for the coming storm
i'm going to be talking about a way to
get extra cash right now if you already
have a youtube channel somebody will pay
you for your back library which is nice
to have a little extra bread to weather
you know what's coming and then finally
why actually this recession
could be
beneficial and why this could be an
opportunity if you respond and adapt
your business accordingly all that and
more is coming up today on the coffee
with kennel show what is up sean cannell
here rhymes with youtube channel and i'm
fired up for the coffee with kennel show
today what we do is in the beginning for
the first 20 minutes or so i'm going to
be sharing a lot of tactical advice with
you some brand new information and news
that you need to know but stick around
because towards the end of the video i'm
going to be breaking down three specific
strategies that i think can bring a
little bit of optimism and opportunity
in the midst of some very real hardship
that is already here and coming our way
as creators entrepreneurs and business
owners and in part two of the show we do
q a so you can stick around for that as
well and if you have a question we'll
get to that a little bit later smash
like if you are fired up today for the
content
and uh we're gonna get straight into
this now let's kind of get a uh bearing
on what's happening here and what we're
gonna to cover
business insider recently released this
article how creators can prepare for a
recession according to a top manager
with clients like mr beast and actually
reid dasher released
a email and a document on linkedin that
has some powerful advice and we're going
to be covering those tips and more in
this video here's screen daily though
and it says why major streamers are
reevaluating how they do business amidst
recession fears
you know netflix has lost a lot of
subscribers um and there is a lot of
tech companies that are slumping in a
major way right now
warner brothers discovery dropped 27
uh of its market um recently and amidst
rising inflation and rising interest
rates especially tech companies are kind
of backing off a little bit in fact this
article says that layoffs are hitting
the creator economy and eight startups
have cut staff since may now this means
startups that actually serve the crater
economy like sub stack cameo jelly smack
and they're actually laying off staff so
these are signals that of course you and
i need to be paying attention to now
watcher guru
on twitter said this just in coinbase
has lawyer lowered payouts to social
influencers due to market conditions
this is the cryptocurrency website
coinbase that would be paying for
influencer marketing paying for
influencers maybe like you've seen like
a graham stefan sponsored by a comb
coinbase they're lowering those payouts
now of course the crypto winter is kind
of already here uh but again these are
signs and signals that we need to be
paying attention to and before we get
into the first six tips before the
three tips that i have for you towards
the end
uh we actually have some really valuable
content from uh
miguel lozada here and he says this
craters and influencers public service
announcement i've personally had four
out of the six q3 q4 paid activations
canceled last week doesn't mean panic
but it's time to start making sure you
are prepared for a possible rough patch
time to start thinking and planning now
versus later and i want to cover these
things he had to consider but just in
case just to have make uh explain this a
little bit if you're new to this
a lot of
creators in fact not many of the
creators necessarily that subscribe to
the think media podcast because in our
world it's a lot of business owners
entrepreneurs diversified revenue
streams but the primary business model
in the creator economy of kind of
entertaining creators or
many right would be of course youtube ad
revenue and then working with brands and
so what
miguel is saying here right is that he
has had four
uh out of six deals for this second half
of 2022 cancelled by brands and so um
one of the big things we do at think
media is we do brand deals it's over a
million dollar business for us and so
we're preparing as well to say okay wait
a minute we might not be able to depend
on this revenue in the same way because
most of the brand deals we also work
with right are actually tech companies
buzz sprout vid iq
and so these tech companies with staffs
they're preparing they're looking at the
layoffs that are happening in tesla and
all these different places and so here's
some of the strategies just as kind of a
primer for today's episode that he says
he's saying that companies are going to
be spending less on activations
and less on paid digital media so plan
for less money from youtube ads and
expect twitch new ad incentive program
to take a hit too
so you can secure the bag while it's
still offered also you're going to get
less money from brand partnerships and
activations now we also should note here
that
of course
this isn't fear-mongering you know you
might see the thumbnail and the title on
this video and say that that's click
bait it's not click bait this is very
real information um but you know here at
think media like we don't have a spirit
of fear we have a spirit of power and of
love and of a sound clear thinking uh
mind that just adapts accordingly we're
not ignorant to what's happening in the
marketplace and in the world um we want
to be aware so we can plan and that's
what today's real episode is about
is this stuff a guarantee to happen well
you can't say it's a guarantee but the
probabilities are pretty high as we are
seeing these signs and signals uh you
know if if you see smoke
there's probably a fire so you know
let's keep going supporters and viewers
will be going through the same rough
situation
don't expect the same uh tendency of
gifted subs donations and regular subs
also don't be tone deaf bring up free
ways people can show support watching
your content and gaining on socials etc
so his tips here are that not only
might youtube ad revenue go down and my
brand partnerships pull money out of the
system but also
as layoffs are happening your viewers
um could be in a situation where they're
going through a rough situation as well
so they might not be doing in this case
you know donations super chats
people have a lot less money for just
your t-shirt on teespring your merch and
so people might be they're gonna be more
careful with their dollars or their
dollars might evaporate they might go
through hard times and
also don't be tone deaf if you're
insulated from any kind of recession
it's not a really good look when hard
times are happening and you're flexing
and taking pictures on a private jet or
just completely unaware of what's
happening in the world and in the market
right
and so here's a couple more tips from
miguel before we get into the six tips
and uh he says this look over
uh
look over your spending recently and
start budgeting now set limits and start
saving where you can and if you can so
be wise with your money now this could
be simple things or even accepting now
is not the time to go full time or maybe
it's a good time to pick up a small
part-time job and get some extra cash
really wise this might just be a rough
patch for six months or 18 to 24 months
no one knows but the signs show it's
time to prepare for things
before they really start getting rough
and then you have another creator here
verified on twitter saying i just lost
my facebook contract after seven months
with them a lot of companies are cutting
and you can see this twitter thread as
well if you're interested and so there's
a lot there's smoke and so that means
there's probably a fire of brewing and
if you are just joining the stream again
this isn't hype about there being a
recession the media is not really
talking about it and a lot of media
outlets are saying like maybe we're
going to go into a recession
what a recession is is two consecutive
quarters
of the gdp going down and not going up
so we're already there based on the
definition see forbes said u.s recession
is already six months old says a fed
model and so in a way semantics may or
may not matter in this case
but i think the big idea is that this is
one of the most important videos that
you could be watching right now there's
no
better
strategy than to have foresight than to
look ahead than to prepare than to see
danger coming
and to position yourself ahead of time
most won't so i encourage you
grab something to take notes with you
know
really block out some time because i
want to give you some really practical
strategies and inside of the thinking
that we're doing here at think media so
that you ultimately don't get crushed in
the coming calamity but ultimately you
can thrive and crush it and at least
survive and weather the storm or
potentially even
see your greatest season of growth and
i'm going to be sharing with you some
powerful stories
of creators that i've interviewed over
the years whose careers were birthed
in a previous recession you know the
truth is that i know you may have
personally experienced ups and downs
over the last few years
maybe you've been through different
economic hard times but the creator
economy itself
really hasn't seen
a recession yet
here's what i mean the last major u.s
recession was back when the
housing bubble burst the big shorts when
everything crashed that's when my wife
and i actually got crushed i mean it was
the hardest season of our life back then
we actually had two houses on declared
income an armed mortgage a family living
in one of the houses with us so because
we saw it as an investment tenants
renting the other one and when the
economy crashed right around 2009
the tenants couldn't pay any more we
couldn't float that the family that we
were living with in our house renting we
actually were living with a family
husband and wife and their daughter and
renting out another room and it was us
in the house in order to make everything
work
they all move out so we're getting
crushed in that house that house has to
short sell the other house four closes
during that same season our church
collapsed because of actually nothing
related to this recession but some
people stole some money and so i was
losing that flow of income i'm waiting
tables at red robin and that was the
season when my wife got really sick and
almost died as well so i've been through
this before so i've got a few scars and
a few you know
challenging things i've been through
that i think will be helpful for you as
we dive into these tips but since that
time
the word creator economy didn't even
exist then and there really hasn't been
a recession since 2010
if you look at the markets it's gone up
and up and up and up interest rates have
stayed low
and
even in 2020
lots of sectors got crushed
and during the pandemic and different
things however
creators views went up because when
people were locked down a lot of people
were watching more youtube than ever
before that was the narrative we heard
the most
for those that were creating content
because people all the sudden had a
bunch of time on think media our views
and you can see it we didn't even post
new content i mean we were posting new
content but
all of our past videos which is what we
teach in video raked academy and whatnot
right we had all this library of
valuable content
as soon as the lockdowns happen we went
from about a hundred thousand views a
month just consistently on search based
to two hundred thousand we just saw an
instant jump as people were at home
locked down
so what we're entering into now is
different than where we've been
before we're entering into
real obviously a war is going on
inflation is skyrocketing you've
probably felt it at the gas pump you may
be feeling it at the grocery store you
may be feeling it with used cars
furniture you may be seeing it real
inflation is happening real layoffs are
happening
real global disruption is happening
and
therefore this recession and even during
2020 brand deals weren't really pulling
back they were leaning in this is now
starting to finally hit the crater
economy for the first time so creators
might not be ready for this and so with
that i want to dive into these six tips
for you and what to do and these are
inspired i'll add a little bit to them
from my standpoint and i've pivoted a
little bit but this article that reed
released or this kind of public service
announcement that he released um that he
put on linkedin
really broke down some some things and
i'll link this in the description later
when i optimize the video uh but let me
dive into these tips for you and uh
definitely massive credit to read ceo of
night but here we go
number one prepare for lower ad revenue
and so
reed suggests that you plan for a 30 dip
in ad sense and brand partnerships over
the next 12 to 24
months
and we've already seen it graham stefan
did a video about his cpm dropping
the document another number is that your
rpm what's the difference between your
rpm and your cpm right your
your
cpm is how much money your channel gets
total so let's say you have a 10 cpm
that's how much money youtube can charge
for brands to advertise on your videos
your rpm revenue per ml cost per mil
your rpm is the money you actually keep
and a lot of times
what they say is that it should be 50 50
but we don't really see it being 50 50.
like if we have a cpm of just for simple
numbers
ten dollars our rpms a lot of times like
four and a half
maybe five or 380 or something so all
that to say is that the both num both
numbers are correlated and whichever way
you want to slice it let's simplify
prepare for lower ad revenue i think
it's just a good idea to always be
prepared for
uh the worst there's actually a proverb
that says you know
do your best prepare for the worst trust
god to bring the victory it's like why
not assume that the best is gonna happen
but prepare for the worst situation to
happen and then also just have faith
throughout the entire process
i think that's a really good uh
positioning to have and these are rough
estimates based on previous instances of
ad revenue downturn on youtube and so um
i think that those are some good metrics
so if you haven't really been into
budgeting before or you haven't really
been into planning before i think you
should take any number you're getting
right now and
you could take
30 off of that and then say okay that'd
be my new operating budget let me just
take the money that's coming in assume
it's going to drop say 30 percent
and then and then operate accordingly as
opposed to living large on uh money that
may be
drying up over the next 12 to 24 months
number two stack cash
now now this is really cool um there's a
couple um startups
that you should know about retalks about
these
startups like spotter creative juice and
jelly smack
spotters one who i recently spoke at
vidcon talked to a bunch of people from
the spotter team if you haven't heard
about this before this is you really
need an established catalog of youtube
videos but here's what this company does
if you go to spotter and if you qualify
this would assume you have a good
library of content
i think a lot of times they say at least
100 videos and your content has some
real value to it like their your old
library is is being viewed
what they actually do
is you let you license your back catalog
to them now watch not your
new videos but like starting say at the
end of this month
everything previous gets licensed to
them and they actually pay you one lump
sum of money now it's a five year
license at the time of recording these
are the terms and of course i'm sure
they do different negotiation
but what what's happening is they're
going to take your back catalog
and instead of youtube running ads on it
they just kind of like a old-school mcn
they run ads on it
uh instead and so they can negotiate
their own ads so it might sound sketch
but it's a completely solid company mr
beast works with them a lot of big
youtubers work with them and in in some
cases for super huge
influential high view channels
people are getting million dollar checks
multi-million dollar checks now if
you're watching this it's probably not
going to be true for you or i
but the chance of maybe getting 52k
156 000 in fact a friend of mine i heard
about their story they have a yoga
channel worked with them
their past catalog and even some of
their new content with they were much
more of a mid-sized creator
and i think they were able to negotiate
something like 68 000 or 142 000 for
their back catalog
and again
there's
spotter which is the the company you can
look them up
they're of course trying to get a good
deal but they're also risking with you
as well like the value of your back
catalog and if you're going to keep
making new videos here's the reason that
this strategy is being recommended stack
cash
now
is because it's nice to have money in
hand
ahead of a potential recession but it's
also nice to have money in hand so that
you can invest and scale your business
now like money today potentially is
better than theoretical money tomorrow
and so you can read more about this
but
these deals also might be
a little bit harder to come by even in
the years to come because jelly smack is
one of these companies they just laid
off eight percent of their staff so the
terms might even be changing but acting
fast now would be a better time to act
than waiting until
the middle of death valley like if you
see it coming it might be smart to get
into suspicion so that's get it it might
be smart to get
positioned now that may if you're new to
youtube that probably doesn't apply to
you uh
but some of our listeners may really
want to check that out but let's talk
about a couple other thoughts for stack
cash
now
do anything you can to save
and to uh
be wise with
money now one of the things that
i
am thoughtful of at think media is how
do we cut our spending
how can we be
uh more smart with how we're saving
how can we do certain activities to get
cash you know there's some companies for
example that will buy or use camera gear
um and there's companies that will maybe
you want to flip some couches like flip
some couches sell your used camera gear
there's a cool online website the the
website escapes me i talk to them at
vidcon
you know downsize maybe
like
this is a whole separate note but uh
right now the housing market in some
areas seems to be impervious to this but
it really depends on looking at your
local market because right now in vegas
i just saw some crazy data there's like
200 houses coming on the market a week
you go on zillow a lot of people are
dropping their price by 50k luxury homes
by 100k so what is that telling us it's
just actually telling us that it
actually could be a lot harder to claim
the peak of your house price if you're a
homeowner
in three six months nine months
and you could actually
liquidate your home now
for a premium price
rent and then reinvest in the recession
just like
that again
no financial advice in this video really
but it's just stat cash now i mean sean
what are you trying to say i'm trying to
say stack cash now is what i'm trying to
say right and so be wise that's a really
great strategy and thought
as it comes to this number three
diversify
your income streams and so
you know this is one of our favorite
tips and one of the biggest things i
recommend all the time here in our think
media world and i think that you as a
creator in this world are already
thinking this way but what does this
mean it means that don't if ad revenue
goes down 30
or you're cool you got other income
streams like at think media
what that would be frustrating but not
fatal
if our brand deals go 30 down 30 percent
that's gonna be brutal but we're gonna
be okay why because we also have
e-learning products we also have digital
courses why because i also have a book
that's self-published youtube secret
second edition just came out it sells
about one to two thousand copies a month
because it's ranked on amazon that's
like organic traffic finding it
the ebook the audiobook and the physical
book
actually the margins on that book are
pretty good because it's self-published
and so
that's another income stream you know on
top of that i k speaking is an income
stream consulting is an income stream um
creating content we don't do a lot of
like done for you content really through
think media but we can turn our skills
towards doing video production work
marketing work
running paid media for other people
that's another income stream
and so explore other monetization
opportunities
uh and let me know actually what are
your
income streams right now have you
already started making money on youtube
and what are some what are the best
income streams for your niche if you're
not sure this is another one to get
educated on you know we uh have all
kinds of content for you to help you
learn about youtube how to make the most
money how to find the best income
streams for you because it depends on
your niche
and
there would be tip number three for not
just surviving but thriving um and
weathering the storm in the midst of the
crater economy recession now we're going
to get into three more tips plus some
good news in the midst of all of this
but i want to say today's episode is
brought to you by the think media
podcast we're so excited
even though i know the news in this is
heavy but we are so committed to
creating our podcast
to help you weather the storm and guess
what it's free every single tuesday we
release an episode of the podcast it's
free to you to listen to so check out
this quick video and we're going to get
into the rest of the tips in just a
second are you looking for the best
youtube marketing and money making
strategies for growing your online
business faster well then make sure that
you subscribe to the think media podcast
every single tuesday we release a power
pack actionable podcast episode where
sean and heather cover the latest
advanced strategies for growing faster
on youtube they bring on industry
experts and pick their brains on how
they can use youtube to grow with their
business and how you can too and so if
you want to find the think media podcast
be sure to check it out on spotify apple
podcast or on youtube and simply search
think media podcast wherever you like to
listen to podcasts or just go to
thinkmediapodcast.com
[Music]
all right we are talking about six
tips of really how creators can prepare
for a recession according to a top
manager with clients like mr beast and
let's get into tip number four which is
make a firm financial plan alright so
how do we get ready and again you might
be wondering like sean what if a
recession doesn't happen though because
there's two camps right now right
there's the camp that's seeing the
writing on the wall and that's saying
man look at the crypto crash look at the
market crash look at the layoffs and
then some people are saying these are
not actual indicators we may get through
this okay well here's the thing
if we get through this but you are more
conservative more strategic you position
yourself better
if we get through this and you've just
saved more money
double down on your content strategy
been more wise been more intelligent and
tighten your belt
well then you're gonna be even better
positioned if this video about recession
is wrong
but if
this video is not wrong and you go ah
nah everyone's just saying peace peace
don't worry it's no big deal then you're
gonna get crushed
if you don't position yourself wisely so
in one scenario
it's just smart to be smart on the other
scenario it's risky to just hope things
are going to be a certain way and then
be surprised by whatever happens so
number four as far as make a firm
financial plan
i don't see any downside to doing this
and so this a couple steps that reid
recommended one
you should have a sense of where all
revenue is coming from now let me speak
to you if you're in the side hustle
season
you should be really auditing your
revenue right now anyways okay how much
is coming in really from work
you maybe you have a spouse you have a
partner how much is our dual income
where's money coming in you may want to
pick up a side job you know is there
and i mean besides your creative videos
okay i'm going to drive uber lyft a
couple uh days a week where's the money
coming in and then
if you do have online income coming in
you're asking okay how much ad revenue
is coming in if i look back a few months
where's the money coming from and maybe
you have some affiliate programs how
much is amazon bringing in
you've got your youtube ad revenue how
are things going there
you've got you did create a course or a
book or some kind of product or merch
really evaluating your revenue streams
and then be asking
how are you spending money like where's
the money going out so pull out that
credit card statement this could be a
time to trim some of those expenditures
if you're a little bit further along you
might be asking and we're kind of
thinking about this i think media we
have 23 people
and of course one of my goals is no
layoffs and we're nowhere near that
thank god and i think because of wisdom
because i'm very i'm a an extra
incredibly conservative leader i try to
live extremely below our means even as
we've had incredible seasons at think
media i'd never want that to go to my
head but
i asked now billy our executive producer
i started saying listen billy
you really got to add up we're talking
about make a firm financial plan you got
to say okay
now we we pay an editor someone helps us
make a thumbnail we've got um
the content creator themself being paid
and then we have how much money does
that video earn what's the adsense that
comes in from it how much affiliate can
we correlate affiliate income and if a
brand is paying us how much is that and
are we losing money let's say it cost us
these days at think media 2 342 to make
a video which in some cases could be
true you add up all the different things
and even have some support staff
and therefore there's a real arbitrage
that we have to consider
yes brandi oh yes affiliates yes
whatever but we only make
1921 well that's not a good strategy
to lose money like that's not going to
be very sustainable so
depending from advanced to beginner like
you want to be thinking about what's
coming in what's going out how can you
tighten your belt
uh per video and honestly how much is it
costing you to post a video is one of
the questions reed asks
how much is it costing you
if it takes you eight hours to do a
video
how much time does it take you to do a
video in your side hustle season
well it takes me eight hours well again
practically you might say okay
can i pick up more time at work over
time do a side hustle side business one
of the questions we ask all the time is
what is our shortest path to revenue
maybe you simplify your content creator
schedule you narrow it down more
intelligently i'm gonna start doing a
video podcast
i'm gonna hire repurpose house or one
virtual editor and that might sound
crazy you might be like wait i'm
tightening my belt but i'm hiring no
you're streamlining you're gonna drive
lift uber
shoot once a week hire an editor for
a very affordable rate
and then
really streamline your content
production realizing you can't
shoot for 10 hours edit for 15 because
that's the hours are being used too and
efficiently just throwing some stuff at
you
to really figure out right if you're in
a good spot or a vulnerable vulnerable
spot and then to make a plan accordingly
number five be prepared with a rainy day
fund come on dave ramsey or my dave
ramsey fans out do you have your
emergency fund
and so uh you know
here's my advice you know this is a
great tip from reed but i was listening
to my friend whiteboard finance
and he was saying this all of us
should well first of all pay down bad
debt what's bad debt you got to get your
credit cards with 14
20
28 percent apr crushing you you got to
get those things paid off any really
high interest debt that could be one of
your hemorrhaging that's where you're
really bleeding right
and then after you do that you want to
save up an emergency fund that's six
months
of what it would cost for you and your
family to live so you've got that margin
what if you get sick what if you get
hurt smart going into a recession but
whiteboard finance shared a great tip
and he was saying
marco right was saying if you're an
entrepreneur or solopreneur or solo
creator you need 12 months
because you're in you're in a more
vulnerable spot
and uh i think wisdom is wisdom so at
least six months
again if you're more advanced here at
think media
i think about not just my wife and i's
emergency fund but i think about the
team that we employ
and having
a year's worth of what does it cost to
operate our business how could we lower
monthly expenses and then also how could
we carry
an entire group of people and their
children and their families through
a recession and so prepare with a uh
rainy day fund and reid mentioned like a
lot of creators don't do this
uh they don't really have budgets they
don't really know how much money they're
spending and if you're like me you might
say sean that's me in fact let me know
in the chat
like let me know in the comments
if you're not really a budgeter
you're not really a
uh
money numbers math person i'll tell you
this i personally am not
my wife thank god has been the
perfect complimentary counterpart she's
actually our cfo
she has always balanced our checkbook
has kept us in financial health
but i have had to learn
and increase my financial education
because there's no way i could be the
ceo of think media at the level we're at
without really getting educated about
money where is it coming in where is it
going how much we spending
what is our reserves and so if you're
more like me just commit to getting a
financial education you may never really
be like the really geeky math person my
recommendation is marry somebody who is
right and uh but ultimately
uh uh thank god she does a really
detailed p l for us every month keeps us
going
sends us warning flags
not just in our business income but of
course our personal income uh but
nevertheless uh
get in the know
of your numbers
number six all right is be conscientious
of hard times and in just a second i do
have three
really good news things for you
specifically for youtube and why this is
actually going to be an opportunity for
youtube creators
and so if you've really been enjoying
this content i know it's heavy but i
definitely appreciate if you hit like
and maybe tag or share this with
somebody because i think this is a
pretty important video in light of
what's coming and um
number six be conscientious of hard
times so reid is just recommending here
that you want to be in touch with events
going on in the world uh and i quote
it's
seeing this weird trend coming back to
youtube where a lot of creators are
taking extravagant flights i spent 40
000 on a flight uh it's you know that's
a great youtube video but 18 months from
now when the world's struggling it's
probably not the video we should film we
see this disconnect with kim kardashian
and different people and i know watching
this kim's probably not watching this
right now and you're like listen i'm not
in a situation where i could take a 40
000 flight but i think
all of us
can be just
wise and more tuned in to the tone of
what's happening in the world and just
sensitive because you might be doing
really well
your a recession for you
might look like cutting luxury
when for somebody else it might really
look
like cutting essentials for living
and so just a really good piece of
advice for
considering how can this and should this
influence your content strategy which is
actually what we're about to talk
because there's three things
i think you really need to know
in regards to
uh the good news of this recession i
don't mean the good news for those that
uh will struggle the most or any of that
or any being tone-deaf or insensitive to
that but there's something true about
recessions um and that is that some of
the greatest companies have been started
during recession albert einstein said in
the middle of difficulty lies
opportunity napoleon hill said that
every adversity every failure every
heartbreak break
carries with it the seed of an equal or
greater benefit and so
back in 2001 when the dot-com bubble
burst mailchimp was founded
in 2009 airbnb uber groupon and square
were all founded in the very middle of
an absolute crash here in america
and so i'm going to be telling you a
story in just a second of a youtuber
that i emailed back in the video that i
interviewed back in the
video influencers days
and how she positioned her channel to
really help people serve people make a
massive difference but then also grow
wildly
during an economic shift and so i'm
gonna take a sip of water and let's look
at uh our sponsor again which is just me
sponsoring our own show with our own
show which is our podcast and again i am
more fired up than ever before myself
the think media team
to
get free content in your hands over the
next 18 to 24 months and beyond but
we're pivoting to really get you
just a whole other level of intensity to
get you strategic
actionable
practical
tactical
wisdom
for starting a business online growing
your youtube channel your revenue
pivoting and being smart and intelligent
and just giving you the best advice and
the best knowledge we can bringing on
our friends and guest experts and that
happens weekly on our podcast so if you
haven't subscribed on audio or to the
youtube channel definitely check out the
think media podcast i'm gonna take a sip
of my cold brew coffee i guess it is
coffee with cannell today and so we
definitely want i should change
i gotta change the branding like what am
i even thinking
man there it is if you look in the upper
corner where the coffee with candles
show we got the black and unsweetened
brazilian coffee keeping it fired up
today i'm going to take a sip here and i
got three more tips for you and then
we'll answer some questions in just a
second are you looking for the best
youtube marketing and money making
strategies for growing your online
business faster well then make sure that
you subscribe to the think media podcast
every single tuesday we released a power
packed actionable podcast episode where
sean and heather cover the latest
advanced strategies for growing faster
on youtube they bring on industry
experts and pick their brains on how
they can use youtube to grow with their
business and how you can too and so if
you want to find the think media podcast
be sure to check it out on spotify apple
podcast or on youtube and simply search
think media podcast wherever you like to
listen to podcasts or just go to
thinkmediapodcast.com
[Music]
all right so we are talking all about
how creators can prepare for a recession
uh according to a top manager with
clients like mr beast but in this next
part i just want to pivot uh with three
practical tips
um that i've learned being really on
youtube since 2007 and so the gray in my
beard is real um i
the first youtube channel i started was
for my church in 2007
um in 2009
i started a channel called clear vision
media you can actually see this old
stuff is for my video production
business it's still out there a bunch of
wedding videos hip-hop music videos for
seattle rappers
my canon vixia camera i was creating
content and then eventually my canon 7d
and then think media started in 2010
i've helped a lot of other youtubers uh
grow their channels i've been a
videographer for many creators uh fast
forward i've interviewed hundreds of
creators and entrepreneurs that have
leveraged online video now and so from
my perspective i think i have some
unique advice that could be really
really helpful for you and i think this
could be one of the most powerful videos
you watch this year in terms of
preparing for what's here and what's to
come when it comes to uh thriving on
youtube and here's the big idea
this is the time to go all in on youtube
and here's why number one people will be
looking for answers and free content
so the cool thing about youtube is you
have a chance to really serve people and
make a difference in the lives of others
for free
and because even if ad revenues go down
because you can get paid for your
viewership through the youtube partner
program listen brands are not going to
stop advertising
highs and lows in the economy brands are
still going to want to get in front of
people they may be paying less the
numbers might go down but nevertheless
you can still have a stream of income
because people will be looking for
answers and for free content see every
recession
creates problems
and entrepreneurs
solve problems for a profit
but the really cool thing about this is
again you can let youtube pay the bill
brands and sponsors pay the bill and you
could serve the end user who could be in
a place where they're really hurting
and so
this is definitely a time to consider
and how can i go all in on youtube
and get positioned now to watch answer
the questions that people are asking and
will be asking when it
when hard times hit us in the world
number two
ask what problems will the recession
create and i want to tell you a story
so i did an interview with a creator
called do it on a dime and she started
in 2011 so this was still the time where
uh things were tough the housing market
was an absolute bottom people were
really the whole american economy was
devastated today she has 2 million subs
268 million views it's crazy and when
she told me her story she was telling me
like sean
what i realized was i started my youtube
channel and the people were hurting
and so i started a
channel called do it on a dime
how to save money how to stretch the
dollar further so if you start thinking
about okay man it's a recession
the ship is going to sink we're all
doomed it's never true there's going to
be some sectors that get hit and crushed
so a lot of times luxury sectors you
know you fast forward a few months ago
and if you were to go buy a mercedes g
wagon people were overpaying 50 000 for
them now there's 50 of them 100 of them
on the lot and they can't even get
asking price they got to reduce the
price
things like the luxury
market and super
uh
like
extravagant
spending goes down for many people no
matter what income level they're at on
the flip side though everyone's asking
how do i make my dollar go further so
here's some strategy for you am i
suggesting that you start a new channel
not necessarily but this could influence
your content strategy
how can you help people save money
how can you help people make a dollar go
further
and maybe you want to start a new
channel
remember in 2009
uber started in 2009 airbnb groupon and
square started and these businesses uber
became a unicorn became worth multiple
millions of dollars right
and so
multiple billions
and so there may be a new channel you
start
because you see what's coming
and just like do it on a dime who's
still thriving today in any economy
but really got her growth because of
smart positioning in a certain season
albert einstein said in the middle of
difficulty
lies opportunity
and napoleon hill said every adversity
every failure every heartbreak break
carries with it a seed of equal or
greater benefit
so
ask yourself what problems will the
recession create
if you think about it the cool thing
about youtube is you can offer something
like if you're a fitness trainer you can
offer free workouts free yoga routines
free stretching classes
youtube pays you ad revenue
brands might sponsor your content once
you have enough influence
but the end user
who lost their job is maybe laid off
can connect with you
and you can monetize and be benefited in
that exchange but also think about
when you serve people maybe in their
hardest seasons then when they bounce
back
they have that connection with you and
as times shift because i think that's
also the good news
seasons always change yes we are in a
recession and yes the creator economy
could go into an intense recession but
seasons will always change
and so when you serve people and when
you stay focused and when you add value
and when you bring encouragement then
ultimately those connections can be made
that when people are now prospering
they'll look back with a heart of
gratitude
and
you can launch out of the recession
where people start saying you know i
wasn't able to back then support you or
give to your patreon or do any of that
but now i can why because you are
thoughtful and intentional about putting
in the hustle to really
serve people and offer something for
free that's valuable like workouts let
me give you another example you could
you could offer high value education for
free here's one of my favorites um i'm
watching this channel called
productivity game
and it's book summaries for free and
they're phenomenal
so a lot of times they're seven or eight
minutes they're kind of like whiteboard
book summaries and i've thought about
subscribing to something like blink lit
blinkist or those types of things i
haven't got around to it michael hyatt's
but then i realized i was like these
things are this this is
worth 10 bucks a month 20 bucks a month
25 a month and it's free on youtube now
obviously productivity game can build a
big business
because of youtube ad revenue
and so what is high value
education that you can give away for
free on youtube and you have an
incredible opportunity and blessing
that youtube
google will pay you
if that content really serves people and
finally what is some high quality
entertainment that you could also give
away because think about it
one of the things i'm into is is
these videos that are like really high
quality documentary stories
about um like rob deredict was one i i
watched recently and i'm forgetting the
channel names but it was like how he
dominated youtube took over
their show with ridiculousness and it's
an opc strategy other people's content
fair use
pulling wikipedia articles clips off of
youtube
photos
but it's making original content
not easy like really rich original
thoughtful influence searching strategy
trend surfing strategy we teach that
like in our you know community and our
vra program we talk about that stuff in
depth like of of how you could do that
but the big idea is it's high value
entertaining content that's kind of
edutainment because i love learning from
someone like a rob deredict
and ultimately
i watch to the end of these videos i
throw them up on my smart tv
23 minutes 32 minutes
this is high quality entertainment
that i'm watching on youtube
and remember in this ecosystem people
are making money
um through that ad revenue i don't i
don't have to pay for a netflix
subscription to watch that i can watch
that for free and either ads can play or
i i do play pay for
youtube red let me give you one more tip
here
and i think this one's probably the most
important when it comes to how can
creators survive the recession and even
thrive you got to make a determination
to weather the storm now here's what i
mean
there's something about positioning
yourself now to just have the mental
toughness that i'm going to do whatever
it takes i'm not going to quit i'm not
going to give up
i'm going to weather the storm and
here's the my favorite illustration of
this have you seen the movie forest gump
there's a scene in forrest gump
where forest and lieutenant dan make a
decision to start
in the shrimping business they buy a
boat a used boat they go out and they're
trying to
fish for shrimp but it's an empty net
it's an empty net it's just not working
and they're super frustrated and then
one night a terrible storm comes around
and the storm about destroys them
lieutenant dan is hanging out on the top
of the
sail god if you get us through this you
know uh then then i'll actually serve
you kind of a thing and forest is
you know making the ropes and and
getting the whole thing and they go
through this crazy storm that shakes
everything and if you've seen forrest
gump you'll remember that the next day
they uh are are boating and trolling
through the waters near near shore and
all the other boats are washed up all
the other boats have been pushed on land
they're they're they're they're broken
holes there's damage to the other boats
and now they're the only
shrimp boat that is still
standing right they put down their nets
and now it's nets full of shrimp nets
full of shrimp nets full of shrimp
because they
weathered the storm you know when i say
determined to weather the storm it's
just this truth
that
unfortunately a lot of people and i say
this with empathy but it's just true a
lot of people are going to shrink back
in fear
a lot of people are going to going to
allow bad news and recession to paralyze
them
a lot of people
are not going to
intentionally build the character the
confidence and the mindset to weather
the storm
but if you make a commitment to say i'm
going to be wise with my finances
i'm actually going to double down
even to be out on the waters at night
to be able to actually
fight through the storm so that when it
clears
all the sudden your bubba gump shrimp
company
and there's more shrimp than ever before
unfortunately a storm will take a lot of
people out but it doesn't have to take
you out
and so i would make a determination even
right now to say i can weather this
thing while many will shrink back i'm
going to go forward and our
ethic here at think media
is
we're not going to give in to a spirit
of fear
we're not going to allow allow fear to
control us
you know we're going to have caution
we're not going to be delusional but we
do not give in to a spirit of fear
instead
as the scriptures say
we believe god has given us a spirit of
love and of power and of a sound mind
clear thinking
strategic moves
through every season whether it's
recession
or whether it's a season of growth and
thriving in either case we refuse fear
and we choose faith
so i hope that this has been valuable to
you today and in just a second we're
going to uh get into some questions from
you let me know
uh
what a question is that you have dropped
four question marks before and after and
i want to encourage you
if you haven't subscribed to the think
media podcast
um i want you to know that you don't
have to go this thing alone you know
through good and bad seasons
we are here to help you with what we
hope is the best most tactical and
strategic information
for growing a youtube channel getting
subscribers starting a youtube channel
starting a side hustle creating multiple
streams of income breaking through but
sean it feels like competition is so
high yeah it is but consumption is high
as well
and when people sometimes might find
themselves without a job or laid off
then they're looking for answers and so
you want to be that answer for people
while many are needing encouragement you
can be that encouragement many are in
fear you can be that voice of faith
while many are
looking for learning a new skill set or
looking for some type of knowledge you
know you can be that and if you want to
learn how we have a free resource for
you called the think media podcast it
comes out every tuesday
definitely subscribe because
number one forever but def but
especially over the next three six
12
18 24 months we are going to be putting
in extra effort to bring you high value
content
that will really help you
thrive
and survive
any kind of recession that comes
in the creator economy so check this out
and drop your questions with four
question marks before and after and
we'll get into some q a in just a second
are you looking for the best youtube
marketing and money making strategies
for growing your online business faster
well then make sure that you subscribe
to the think media podcast every single
tuesday we released a power packed
actionable podcast episode where sean
and heather cover the latest advanced
strategies for growing faster on youtube
they bring on industry experts and pick
their brains on how they can use youtube
to grow with their business and how you
can too and so if you want to find the
think media podcast be sure to check it
out on spotify apple podcast or on
youtube and simply search think media
podcast wherever you like to listen to
podcasts or just go to think media
podcasts
[Music]
all right coffee with kennel crew thanks
so much for being a part of this episode
drop what was your biggest aha or what
do you need to do next to prepare for
what's coming or what's already here let
me know uh i'm coming to you from
seattle with the road caster over here
so you know that you
you got to just press record
that's right and i'm super fired up
because we are going to be answering
your questions uh retro nerd girl says
any suggestions for income streams for a
film discussion channel during the
recession i think one of the smart
things you could do right now is make a
um
a list you could open up google sheets
which is kind of like an excel document
and you should make a list of relevant
brands
for the audience that you're reaching
when it comes to people that are into
film discussions this could be
brands like
nerd box subscription boxes for maybe
other retro type things other action
figures if that would be that's one that
comes to mind for me you then also maybe
look at other channels and look at the
brands that are sponsoring those
channels now depending on your size it
just doesn't hurt to reach out here's
your goal
list on your spreadsheet
google sheets
10 15 20 30 40 50 brands
two build it out with contact
information you might have a field for
their email if you can find the person's
email address find out who manages
marketing for that brand on linkedin
connect with them follow them find out
who manages marketing or influencer
marketing on twitter connect with them
follow them and look to do biz dev if
anything um also
make a list and
make a field that says affiliate
marketing and can you sign up for an
affiliate program for them you don't
have to actually have a brand deal to do
so um and then another option would be
maybe later they can do a brand deal
with you and so the income stream in
that case would be
you could look at what like sean
chandler talks does uh and
he has audible and when he reviews a
movie like it or one of the recent
batman movies he recommended um an
audible
uh free download where he gets five to
ten dollars per audible sign up um
related to
recommending a graphic novel someone
should buy on amazon or an audiobook of
batman that they should listen to and so
different things like that i think would
tie into your channel um and i really
suggest checking some of those out i am
going to
drop it like it's hot
what just happened there we go
standing desk
going down into sit mode uh-oh
is the camera angle gonna be correct
uh all right let me
let's get this going coffee with kennel
what do you know about this second angle
okay uh smash like if you're getting
value and you're having a good time and
digit hustle network says
what
was this a bad time to start channel
memberships
considering the topic of discussion i
don't think so i mean if you're adding
value in channel memberships people can
always unsubscribe i think it's
preparing that that maybe that is
something that people will take off
their credit cards when they're
tightening their belts a patreon a
channel membership something that
they're subscribed to
but
you know if you're serving your audience
and you're adding value i don't think
you have to worry about that at all
jenny c
in the vra are there opportunities for
individual members to have interactive
conversations with the think media staff
whether in the facebook group or the
or other right now
our
biggest way of doing that jenny is
what's called our growth video boot camp
and so that's our coaching and
accountability program
we're going through
a cohort basically of it right now where
we do an implementation day where
there's a lot of coaching and breakups
in zoom groups and then there's six
weeks of zoom groups and conversation
with heather myself the think media team
the next one starts in october and so
that's the best way to do that of course
other than that just remember that you
have access to
the
tip of the month you have access to the
vra show and we do our best our q a
monthly insider there
we do our best to get as many people as
we can in there and that's you know of
course no extra charge or anything
different so check out those resources
and you can always go to talk
talkwiththink.com if you want to learn
more about the next bootcamp
we also have coaching too but it is it's
pretty expensive just because of the
time it takes to go into it so we are
trying to offer those
you know once people's membership and
vra's paid off they literally have
lifetime access so a lot of people are
benefiting
uh naturally from
uh
you know like if you're in vr right now
you have lifetime access you can benefit
from all the tips and stuff that we're
dropping in the membership group and the
q and a's that we do monthly with some
channel reviews and video reviews and
things like that but otherwise check out
the bootcamp grow with videobootcamp
talkwiththink.com would be the best
place to talk to our team about that
what are your predictions on where
advertiser revenues go in the short term
well they just don't go
anywhere if that's what you're asking i
mean they just they just get
the belt gets taken tightened this messy
area over here is i don't like that
that's messy i wonder if i could oh yeah
i mean that's just a skit that's just
yeah okay uh so what are your
predictions on where advertiser revenues
go in the short term
um a lot of times they're just going to
spend less and
if that's what you mean if you go all
the way back to the beginning of this
video and you're just joining live
based on reid uh mr beast one of mr
beast's managers
he's saying that we could we should
predict a 30
potential drop in rpms and cpms
so i think that's probably a good metric
and that's based on data from the past
what are possible what are questions you
should ask possible affiliate companies
when they approach you if you haven't
done research
um i could have been scammed by a dodgy
company today
i think one of the things that
you have an opportunity up there is
look at their website just look like
there could be almost a spidey sense of
how legit is this so
the quality that's not the only thing
but i would definitely look at their
website you could google their website
as well better business bureau
um
there's some different sites selling
tech
you know maybe in your case maybe it's
gaming accessories and someone says this
site is a scam or something you know
that would of course put off put up red
flags so you're trying to look work with
there's probably a-list companies so of
course like elgato and corsair well
that's going to be like more a-list
there might be some b-list
companies that'd be great to work with
even c but then some don't even fall in
those categories so i just do your due
diligence
um and and what's the worst that can
happen the key is you don't necessarily
want to recommend
something sketchy to your website so if
you haven't fully vetted it and that
brand does not have a reputation you
don't know for sure that it's legit you
haven't done your due diligence and
research i would avoid
working with them at all or definitely
avoid doing any kind of recommendation
because through you someone trusts you
you haven't done your due diligence
and then that ultimately impacts
you know your
reputation uh because people are are
trusting you ultimately when it comes to
that
uh how can i best transition my current
channel christianity explained to ones
that serves up friendly gaming content
minecraft
that's not a transition i would
recommend i don't think that's a good
idea i think that
christianity explained
you're uploading one two three four
fifty a hundred videos on that topic
and then you want to change to minecraft
i think that pivot is too dramatic and
too extreme
um unless you called it and i don't love
this idea but maybe you do you know
the christian minecraft channel
something like that you know
minecraft for christians um
it's not a terrible idea maybe not that
name it's just that
you know uh gospel gamers because you
have to think about the psychology of
why people subscribe to in the first
place but the thing is they subscribed
in the first place if it's christianity
explained
you know explaining this thing in the
bible explaining this thing in history
explaining this verse now you're doing
gaming content
that
signals to me
that you should start
a second channel
which i don't always encourage either
and i would ask why don't you actually
double down on the channel that you're
already doing why pivot you certainly
can but uh just a couple thoughts all
right what in the world
what is the word on brand deals i was
just feeling that it'd be a great part
of income and is it still worth it oh
definitely worth it yeah no brand deals
are are absolutely worth it
um
and uh
there's multiple levels the brand deals
are
the lowest level is like emailing a
company and they go oh yeah we'll send
you like a free sample
you're working with the brand and we'll
let you use the affiliate link
lower than that would just be you just
start using the affiliate link you buy
the product yourself it's not really a
brand deal but it's kind of like the
level so look so level number one
is you find a product you already have
so like i already have a road caster
that's where i can do this money sound
wow
was that the cash register sound i can't
actually hear it cause my headphones are
not on
so i have this road caster
i bought it with money or i think rhodes
said this to us but i bought a lot of
gear with my own money
i can now make a video about it link it
on amazon link it on b h photo and earn
money as an affiliate in fact when we
work with rode to my knowledge they
never paid us so that's level number two
when we
get to know road
we think media have grown our influence
to where companies want to at least send
us free gear pretty cool that's what
waits for you on the other side of the
hustle and your niche
so now we're not being paid but we're
getting a free product and we can
mention that and and disclose that in
the video but we can also link to it as
an affiliate that's kind of the
beginnings of a brand deal the next
level would be you're also being paid so
it will pay you a thousand dollars to
mention and do an ad read in your video
or
we'll pay you ten thousand dollars to
make a dedicated video about this
that
we can use and this is one thing a lot
of smaller creators don't consider
you have a huge opportunity to
use your video production skills you
might go oh my channel's not very big
well you make a dedicated video for a
brand
with
great video production
great education and you negotiate with
them and say you could post this on your
youtube channel you can use this in your
facebook ads you could actually run
my video as an ad
you're not just leveraging your
influence you got a thousand subscribers
5 000 subscribers but you're actually
negotiating more intelligently
to say
i'm going to make you creative
and what i mean is a
video like media creative that they
could run as ads they can post on their
instagram i'll make you a vertical
version of it i'll make you a square
version of it i'll make you the youtube
version of it and so you're biz dev and
hustling
brand deals no matter what size of
crater you are
if you're finding this kind of info
valuable smash like um by the way as
just kind of a general life update i got
a procedure the other day 21 injections
in my elbows wrists
fingers repetitive stress injury carpal
tunnel chronic tendonitis tendinosis
at a place called regenexx
happy to report i'm alive uh the
recovery process is a couple weeks i'm
in week two right now and i can do light
activity i've been out for a bit i mean
we repurpose a lot of content but it's
good to be back coffee with kennel fam
and uh grateful for you
being a part of the think community
and i'm on a journey to recovery the the
prp and the stem cells they drilled six
holes in my tailbone
and extracted six vials
of bone marrow and then they cultivated
my own stem cells out of my own body
and re-injected those into my shoulders
into my c6 vertebrae
so anyways here i am
um and uh
grateful for this and we'll see how it
goes and and the results start kind of
playing out over one two three four
months kind of healing it's technically
non-surgical although they used a drill
in my butt to ultimately extract this
bone marrow that seems pretty surgical
to me but i didn't have to you know cut
my uh carpal
ligament or whatever and uh or get
cortisol shots uh or any of that stuff
which is nice to avoid for the time
being so
anyways that's what i've been up to what
have you been up to hit the like button
for getting 21 injections in two hours
with lots of needles they put me under
thank god all right
sketches and scrubs says any advice for
an art channel
unsure what level of importance people
and brands will place on channels i
create vlogs tutorials and product
reviews
um
listen every business is going to want
to reach their ideal audience and ideal
customers during
good times bad times and recessions
so
people who create canvas
and drawing paper
and colored pencils
and
colored pens
and diy scrapbooking materials
and all of the above
will
still need to do business today and
tomorrow as an art channel you have the
opportunity
to
partner and work with those types of
brands
you also
have the opportunity to again
make videos like
the best budget art supplies on amazon
a title like that
is going to be
a lot more searched and interesting
during
a recession
and so
you can position yourself now to
do
both of those things
your tutorials and your product reviews
are probably your best position type of
content but i also would encourage you
maybe just consider what you mean when
you say i do vlogs because even vlogs
can be very strategic
meaning they show they're more
relational they show more lifestyle but
you could do a vlog style product review
you could do a vlog style tutorial
i think that in your case uh and i we
just highly recommend we understand
there's a whole opportunity for viral
entertainment type of content um but man
education and solving a problem is just
so much more practical not only the
growth on youtube for the average
creator but also for monetization
because when someone is looking
for
the best budget art supplies
then they're in a mindset of realizing
maybe dollars are tight but we're not
going to start stop creating we still
want to express
our creativity so there's a ton of
opportunity for you and while brands
might spend less i think we just have to
accept
that
um
they're still going to spend money
so while ad revenue might be less i
think we just need to accept that
it's still going to they're still going
to be ad revenue so if the mountain gets
steeper we get fitter and just you know
double down on how hard you're working
i'm changing the colors of the room
watch the corner are we going to go
orange in the corner i'm going sunset
havana out here that's a little
okay yeah that's fine
um
phillips hue okay so next question
thanks for the questions y'all
and
let's look at a our aha moment from the
vra fam
use this uncertain time to bring high
value education content to my viewers
i've been sharing inspirational content
now is the top uh time to buckle down
now is the time to buckle down and teach
to better serve i love it great insight
and great aha moment
and
if you're just joining
sorry i'm going to now change
i need to like tie these together better
and just be able to talk to like alexa
oh there we go see that now i'm putting
the dresser lights right behind me
office iris let's get that we're going
to a whole havana
kind of
kind of uh
yeah let's go fairfax there we go
it's not quite it doesn't whatever
like sean stick to the point distracted
uh if you're just joining this one are
probably the most important videos i've
ever made so i really encourage you to
check out the replay save this one and
maybe share this with somebody if you
found this valuable
today if you're asking questions do me a
favor and put four question marks before
and after the question that helps me see
it
and then
i'll be able to
know that it's a question and if you're
enjoying this hit that like button
sketches and scrubs asks how do you
transition from gifting level two
to actual brand deals well
your size of your influence is partly
related to that and so level two you
know just getting a bunch of free
colored pencils which should probably be
like incredibly practical for you
because like what is the cost of like
some colored pencils you know to the
actual brand
which is cool so then how do you
actually get them to start paying you um
a couple practical tips number one build
a media kit
so
um
your media kit just starts saying what
your rates are and now you have a list
of 50 brands to work with as we talked
about earlier at this q a
and you start reaching out to them you
don't maybe just send them your media
kit you ask them are they interested in
a discussion are they even interested
and they say yes
what are the next steps you go well
here's my media kit this is what i
charge we could do one-off video we
could do a three-month partnership a
six-month partnership so you could
consider building out a media kit the
second thing
is you could go to marketplaces i i
forget like back in the day there was a
marketplace called famebit they got
absorbed by
google and youtube and now they are the
brand connect inside of youtube but if
you look up
like brand deal marketplaces there's
four or five of them
and
you can log into these places and brands
it's a middleman
and you can look at the offerings that
are there
whether or not you go through the
marketplace you can see that there's
these five art companies that are even
interested in working with creators and
you could you could go that direction
um
and that's kind of what it is you sort
of just have to shift into it and then
again part of it is building up your
influence
like you know
chances are if you are a micro creator
some brands just may not want to work
with the channel under 10 000
subscribers or under 50 000 that's fine
there's plenty who will
um and so focus on growing your
influence and then
you can have those brands come to you by
the way too make it easy to connect with
you make it easy to connect with you on
twitter make it easy to connect with you
on the email that's on your
page your youtube
about page
make it easy to connect with you on
linkedin
have a professional presence in all of
those places
because you want
any brands the biggest one is going to
be that email address connected to your
youtube channel
because a brand if they find your
channel they find a video you want them
to be able to send a deal directly to
you and that would be one of my favorite
places also to biz dev and hustle is
really optimize your twitter profile and
use it as a way to reach out to
brands so
example the other day
or a while back
i actually was looking for monitors
like i was looking for
you know
let me give you a third angle here why
not can we do that
look at us
no signal that's great there you go so i
was like i was looking for monitors and
i was thinking like how could
i um
you know ultimately
maybe get get free monitors leverage my
influence that i've worked hard for
building think media so i got on twitter
and tweeted asus
vizio
other ones view sonic
and i asked them do you work publicly
because if they don't follow me i can't
dm them
do you ever collaborate or work with
youtubers
in a brand deal fashion or whatever
and i tweet them they maybe follow me
back they maybe tweet me publicly and
they say yes here's the email address
for learning more about that
or
um they follow me and dm me and say yes
you know tell us more about your
channel or whatever it is
so i start with a question i don't start
with tweeting them a media kit
you start with a question to get that
relationship you know going
and then you see where it goes and then
i think the final consideration
is too many people too many creators out
here
are just
taking way too few actions what do i
mean
you
get up
you find three brands you want to work
with you send three tweets and then you
go on your lunch break
it's not good enough
you gotta multiply you got a 10x and
100x the activities that you're doing
when it comes to
putting in hustle to really make it in
the crater economy in good or bad times
so that's why don't come up with three
brands you want to potentially work with
come up with 300 figure out
software apps for diy people drawing
apps figure out every colored pencil
company every pen company every stucco
glue scrapbooking anything relevant to
your niche find think about watch
20 of your competitors look at any of
them that have brand integrations watch
40 of your competitors look at all of
their top 22 products they recommend
budget amazon arts and crafts like
and and build out a spreadsheet with 300
companies to reach out to
optimize your twitter game don't be
pushy or salesy towards a brand but put
a good profile picture on your twitter
optimize your bio get your game cleaned
up
and then tweet
all 300 of those brands
and then
wait until
two weeks go by
and do it again
and so i think a lot of times
the amount of
actions
creators are taking are the reason
there's a gap between the results and
the breakthrough especially when you're
on that come up and that hustle of
course mr beast has a lot of inbound
brands of course we at think media have
a ton of in brown inbound brands that
want to work with us
but don't get it twisted before there
was ever nolan moult and omar el tekori
and heather taurus
sean cannell by himself waiting tables
at red robin and working at a church and
pastoring a campus of a church in irvine
california had to go home
sit down
shoot a video plan a video research a
video tweet some companies
post the video optimize title
description tags that sucker
do it again
on my off day
after work for a few hours after date
night with my wife sonia and then going
to my computer to work for a couple more
hours on my saturday morning when
everybody else is watching cartoons i'm
up tweeting companies there's just
something about putting in
10 30 100 times more hustle than others
not toxic hustle culture but sometimes
you got to live today like no one else
so you can live like no one else in the
future the law of sacrifice is you got
to give up to go up and so i was not
watching
extra seasons of the new
kardashians or the bachelor or
downton abbey during that season of my
life i was focused
on my dreams and so that's what i would
recommend and
that's how you transition you hustle
your way there
hit some uh
hit some like buttons for the rants on a
friday hey tgif the grind includes
friday thank god it's friday thank god
we're free
rising grind we are out here this is the
coffee with kennel show
you gotta just press record
and uh i'm catching up on your questions
got one or two questions uh coming at
you and uh i'm excited to
uh just to be hanging out with you on a
friday
sami zor advice for juggling multiple
channels or deciding which one to focus
on i believe in all of my channel ideas
so it's hard to put
any aside
i'm grateful for this question i'm super
grateful you're here and i've got some
i've got some
good but challenging advice for you
i do not recommend doing multiple
channels
it's hard enough to run one channel it's
hard enough to run one business let
alone two
or three
it's really the power of focus you know
and if you try and chase two rabbits
you'll end up catching neither of them
and so the problem is i have no doubt
that
there are multiple channels
i have no doubt that each of your
channel ideas is a great idea but my
challenge to you is to just pick one and
here's my framework for how you should
pick one i think you should pick one
that's at the intersection
of which one do you love the most i love
them all the same pick one which one do
you love the most which one are you also
potentially best at do you know the most
about which one would help you if you
had to come up with 50 video ideas off
the top of your head which one would be
the easiest to come up with video ideas
you have the greatest depth of knowledge
the greatest the most amount of
experience and then the third question
is which one
could be the most profitable and so that
is a question about
which one is the least competition
on youtube and i'm sure there's a lot of
competition but the least which one
do you have the most fresher unique
angle on it for more on that check out
the book the blue ocean strategy you
could just look at a book summary on
youtube of the blue ocean strategy
which one
could you have your most unique
positioning on which one also could be
the quickest path to revenue but you
might say sean you have multiple youtube
channels true i also have 23 people
working on the think media team so what
i'm suggesting is that when you're in
the solopreneur season when you're
starting out and you're just beginning
something it is so hard to do multiple
things well so really tap into the power
of focus and pick one and when you
discover the quickest and shortest path
to revenue once money's coming in now
you've hired a video editor once money's
coming in
now you actually are able to quit your
day job you have extra time once money
is coming in you're able to get better
software better automation maybe
somebody helping you and so in that
season it could be completely reasonable
for you to start another channel and i
want to share some intense numbers and
of course this is an exact math but i
actually don't think you should start a
second channel depending on the niche
but i don't think you should start a
second channel until you have at least a
hundred thousand subscribers and you're
making a six figure revenue
i am empathetic that in the crater
economy that if you can grow your
channel to 22 000 subs and you're making
52 000 a year
that that's absolutely incredible and
that is
more common than ever before and no
matter what season thriving or recession
that is practical right now but here my
advice
that the person who has one channel and
is earning 50k a year
they should not start a second channel
yet even though
it would be better like if you're at
least doing that then you have way more
intelligence and strategy and right to
do that but i would recommend that even
if you're established some money's
coming in you're kind of comfortable i'm
making 50k i do have a part-time editor
i still think
you should double down and get your 50
000 sub 22 000 sub channel to 100 000
subs because it's going to be easier to
grow the channel that you already have
momentum on it's going to be easier to
get three thousand dollars a month to
four five six seven thousand ten
thousand dollars a month than it is to
start something else from scratch but
sean isn't there an exception to the
rule of course there's exceptions to the
rule but these are just some guidelines
to help you make a practical
strategy and to help you tap into the
power of focus for more on this highly
recommend the book essentialism of
course we'll link up the books if you're
a reader audiobook listener you know
blue ocean strategy the book
essentialism you can check those out in
the youtube description
one of my favorite things is to watch
book summaries on youtube as well you
can watch those for free get the big
ideas you should be an essentialist if
you want to thrive in the crater economy
when there's tons of distractions tons
of shiny objects i want to start three
four five channels great maybe you can
do that eventually but pick one and
focus on it
my friends uh
smash the like button if you're grateful
today i'm going to take a sip of my
mountain spring water and today's coffee
with kennel is brought to you by the
think media podcast i highly recommend
uh if you haven't checked out our new
episodes every tuesday check them out
check out this video are you looking for
the best youtube marketing and money
making strategies for growing your
online business faster well then make
sure that you subscribe to the think
media podcast every single tuesday we
release a power packed actionable
podcast episode where sean and heather
cover the latest advanced strategies for
growing faster on youtube they bring on
industry experts and pick their brains
on how they can use youtube to grow with
their business and how you can too and
so if you want to find the think media
podcast be sure to check it out on
spotify apple podcast or on youtube and
simply search think media podcast
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
or just go to thinkmediapodcast.com
[Music]
welcome back to the coffee with kennel
show my name is sean cannell rhymes with
youtube channel and uh i am on a mission
to
help you
win on
youtube as the standing desk rises and
the shot composition is grossly
compromised uh i want to uh just say i
appreciate you i hope your friday is
going good uh my camera angle is super
messed up now that's a little bit uh
better
and uh we are out here in seattle
washington holding it down helping you
win on youtube hey if you look up on the
wall behind me there's a copy of my book
youtube secrets that's actually the
first edition that's a gnarly beat up
copy um and uh recently we just dropped
the second edition of youtube
secrets if you um
have not
checked out that book you actually can
get it for free at tubesecretsaudio.com
if you don't have an audible account you
can get it for free
but the second edition of youtube
secrets is out here's what it looks like
the updated second edition this is um 80
new pages completely rewritten and cr
re-updated re-updated in part one we go
through the seven c's of youtube success
here they are you gotta start with
courage then you gotta get clear start
with the end of mind clarity three you
gotta set up your channel four you gotta
figure out your content strategy five
you want to focus on your community and
really build super fan six cache how do
you monetize your content seven
consistency you wanna hustle your way to
success and how do you stay consistent
and build systems and rhythms
into your
world and then in part two we kind of
get into advanced stuff the new chapter
the perfect video recipe is worth your
investment into the book alone we talk
about social media completely rewrote
that chapter my views on social media
have dramatically changed um i think
it's great for some of us but the
question is are you in the side hustle
season solopreneur season or scale
season and depending on what season
you're in it should be how you treat
social media talk about discoverability
all the new stuff for what it takes to
rank on youtube which is different now
the original version of this book came
out in 2018 uh trends intent polls
uh team how to scale with a team how to
think differently and new youtube
features so a new youtube a new
chapter all about shorts things like
that
the whole thing is updated 269 pages now
the book is called youtube secrets and
uh it's out on amazon so we have the
ebook
the audiobook
and we have
uh
the
paperback kindle and the audiobook uh
over 2175
reviews at a 4.6 out of 5 rating on the
book and you know would be fun would be
to someday
read the negative reviews because this
isn't going to help my case
waste of time and
money
to save you the burden of reading this
book i will summarize it for you start a
channel find a niche and post
consistently
listen any authors out there me now mind
you then you go over to that's an
unverified review you go over to mike
dice's review who's verified
and you can get the waste of time and
money versus the science of youtube
success these guys have success on
youtube down to a science no tricks or
gimmicks that's the polarization of the
internet are you like me you go to you
go to amazon
it's like 10 000 positive reviews but
you read two negative reviews that are
upvoted and you're just like wait i
don't know if this is
there's like not a product in the world
and you definitely cannot make everybody
happy but i think one of the things uh
not that you asked this is the ship is
sinking sean stop talking about the
reviews don't point out listen if you go
to uh the most recent right that's what
you can do you could go to most recent
you could see actually just uh maybe
even the first version wasn't as good as
the second version which is probably
true the second version is like 10 times
better and so um you could see all these
positive reviews on the books so
anyways youtube secrets is on amazon
just search for youtube secrets or go to
audible and if you don't have an audible
account you can pick up a copy for free
uh if you go to tube secrets
it'll take you right there
if you already own a copy of the first
book
um
on kindle or audio all you got to do is
go into your app and just refresh it you
don't have to rebuy it so kind of a cool
benefit if you bought the original book
you can just update the kindle or the
audiobook without rebuying it if you're
just hearing about this
you would have to buy it you know on
kindle or physically or audio or if you
try audible zero dollars and zero cents
you can do a trial and grab a copy
for
free anybody read uh youtube secrets
have you checked out that book
um let me know and
let me know if you got value out of it
an aha
review
from it
and check that out all right final
questions i got a couple more questions
for you a question
what are your thoughts about
cross-platform content stream to twitch
parlay that into youtube and youtube
shorts ig reels and tick tock
i'll tell you what we do um i'll tell
you the dark side and the good side of
that you know should you repurpose your
content and put it on multiple platforms
i think that
the good side is you can use a stream
a software like stream yard and you can
multi-stream i'm multi-streaming right
now i'm going to my facebook page what's
up facebook we're going to our facebook
group for think media
and we're on our think media podcast
channel
i'm thoughtful about that i hand-picked
those channels to multistream too
i guess we could also go to twitch
beats upon the eye
the dark side about this is that
sometimes if you divide your message
across too many platforms it's hard to
really serve the platform
if you really spend a lot of time
greeting each pla each platform hey
youtube want to shout out facebook hey
twitch hope you guys are doing good over
there hey man we're also on
that twitter one what's that twitter one
called
periscope hey periscope you know what i
mean like you're just in a lot you're
multi-streaming and it could dilute just
the ultimate stream so i think if you're
thoughtful and intentional
multi-streaming can be a good idea i
think the second
opportunity is to actually create really
great content as you asked
we do this with like our video podcast
or this i mean i'm actually doing it
right now the coffee with kennel show
is streaming it's an hour and 33 minutes
and 16 seconds into it right now
and after this clips from this show will
be cut out and posted
on places like my instagram reels and
tik tok
and maybe youtube shorts um and so
i think repurposing gives you a lot of
opportunity and one of the reasons you
know even question and answer can be
good it's one question one answer could
be potentially repurposed other places
the dark side is this i think that
sometimes when people are starting they
try to do too much too soon
so is repurposing great it is but is
doing it as one person can be very
difficult so you can use a service like
repurpose house but it's still going to
take your time and your thinking to give
them the time codes and give them the
strategy you might be able to hire an
individual to repurpose the content for
you and so in some cases here's my best
advice
i like to encourage people to figure out
what is the shortest path to revenue
what is the minimal amount of weekly
tasks you can do to generate revenue
get that revenue coming in
then reinvest that revenue into posting
the content in multiple places and
scaling up team and systems around you
because you can only do so much other
than that just consider like what season
of life are you in because listen if you
don't have a job because maybe
somebody else is the main bread winner
or you're just in a season where you
don't need one or you're already a
solopreneur meeting you're by yourself
but you make a full-time living as a
creator well
decide how much you want to work a week
if you want to work 40 50 60
or whatever then you could do all the
above but you just want to be really
thoughtful with how you're spending your
time and your energy and sometimes the
return on investment of cutting out an
instagram reel
and you have barely any followers on
instagram and it gets a couple hundred
views but like what for
might have been better invested in just
doubling down on better youtube content
whereas maybe eventually
you posting on tick tock and some
repurposed content because someone's
helping you
it doesn't really matter what the quote
unquote roi is of course you want there
to be a return on investment there but
it's it's going to be less
of a distraction from the main thing
focusing on a lesser thing
based on the season that you're in
was that helpful
stone can yawn i show any place for
youtube ads to get more views subs
upfront when building up monetization
um if you mean placing youtube ads like
paying for youtube ads to grow your
viewership and your subscribers
it's usually a bad
idea
it does not map towards real organic
viewership
typically
and
sometimes it can drive some subs but
they're not super engaged the best way
to build up to monetization and the best
way to
build up real engaged subscribers is
with organic
content that wins subscriptions
from real people without
ads
if you're going to use youtube ads you
should run them
to a product or a program
like we we use youtube ads that tell
people about like our free class or
something free and then we have a
product or a program but here's the key
it makes sense because based on the
amount of money we can earn from the
people who see the power of investing in
our online course
makes paying for the ads make sense
paying for youtube ads just to get views
and subscribers
doesn't ultimately make sense and it's
too much of a moonshot pipe dream and
unlikely to happen
to build up to monetization like oh i
invest
50 100 hundreds now so that my channel
gets monetized
i just would not recommend it
gil summarized it in far fewer words
only run ads if selling a product well
said gil great point
um and let's see i purchased the first
version of youtube secrets it was
beneficial thank you for the second
edition you're welcome grateful for the
feedback appreciate you
um and thanks for all the uh
kind words today y'all um i really
appreciate you being here thanks for the
love
in our uh community um it looks like
my wife and son sean bradley and our
friends sarah and her daughter mila just
pulled into the very driveway that i can
see through
the window right here so listen
couple things thanks for checking out
this episode if you're watching live
definitely watch the replay and do me a
favor if you got a ton of value today
this is one of the videos i want to get
into people's hands more than anything
else i just think that the information
we shared
uh
was
powerful practical and so if you know
somebody who is wanting to maybe start a
youtube channel or position themselves
in the creator economy uh would you
share this with them you on facebook you
could you know
click share or tag them in the comments
you know on youtube email this to
somebody or share this with somebody
and then remember every tuesday at least
we're releasing new episodes on the
think media podcast and so um definitely
subscribe on youtube or you can go to
thinkmediapodcast.com
and you can see that we're on all kinds
of platforms and so heather and i are
bringing you weekly content
um we're on apple podcast google podcast
amazon music any of your favorite spots
you can check out past episodes and
there's just um just content to help you
really survive and thrive and we're
going to be having extra focus on really
helping you win
in the coming
months of
a real recession that's happening how
bad will it be we don't know for sure
but regardless we're going to be here
bringing you free information
to help you
get more views grow your subscribers
earn money find brand deals
find
how to position yourself write great
titles make better videos optimize your
videos so many guest interviews coming
up with experts so definitely subscribe
on your favorite podcast platform could
be apple or spotify or on youtube if you
want the video
podcast version of the
podcast
my name is sean cannell rhymes with
youtube channel smash like if you got
video to if you got value today on the
coffee with kennel show and i look
forward to hanging out soon friends
appreciate you are you looking for the
best youtube marketing and money making
strategies for growing your online
business faster then make sure that you
are subscribed to the think media
podcast every single tuesday we release
a power packed actionable podcast
episode where we cover the latest
advanced strategies for growing faster
on youtube we also bring on industry
experts and we pick their brains on how
they're using youtube to grow their
businesses and how you can do it too
you can find us on spotify apple podcast
and youtube just search think media
podcast wherever you like to listen to
your podcast or head to
thinkmediapodcast.com
[Music]